[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
hello walter hi martin are you doing
well
martin i'm still doing the same more or
less as last time yes
okay i hope that was well i can't
remember if it was well so far it's been
well every time even though it hasn't
always been so well it's always been
well
and you have to have a positive outlook
exactly this is the place where
no matter how bad your day is going when
i ask you how it's going you have to say
it's well it's it's perfect
let's open with a word of prayer
our heavenly father
once again we are here we are discussing
important matters and we ask you to
bless and enlighten our minds and we
thank you that we can do these in jesus
name amen
we are continuing with our story
so
let's just reiterate
that one cannot change one story yeah
because i have had occasions when people
said i should change my testimony it is
offensive to some
but you know it's very hard to change
your testimony because that's exactly
what happened right yes or at least how
you perceive how it happened
so
let's continue but before we go into
that
we just want to have a little chat about
some of the events that are happening so
that we don't forget yeah
that we are running on a time table
you know some people are thinking
the lord delays is coming
and after the long delay is it still
relevant that the lord is coming etc now
personally
i don't think there's any delay i think
it's right on time
but that's my personal view which not
everybody will share
but i think that the coming of christ is
imminent
and that's why uh
we are looking at the prophetic
unfoldings with great interest yes
because whatever happens has to fit into
the prophetic picture
because god has never heard
you take the book of daniel yeah
and you see how those kingdoms came and
how these events took place
the fault never lies with god and he
never changes and if it lies somewhere
it lies with us and with our
understanding yes
so let's jump right into it
we are aware that cop 26
is on the agenda
and ecomenism and labor unions will play
a major role in the upcoming events
and we know what prophecy has to say on
these issues so let's just see whether
we are still on track here yes if the
things that happening in the world are
falling in line with what prophecy says
correct
martin i see
america is always
in the midst of things right
i mean that's the horse's mouth that's
it if you want to hear something you
hear it from the horse's mouth yes this
is the jesuit journal
so this is the jesuit review october the
4th 2025
pope francis and 40 faith leaders call
for urgent action to combat climate
change
future generations will never forgive us
so
the church has to have a united voice on
this issue together with the state
now if the church and state unite on an
issue and start legislating
then that's the image of the beast right
fulfillment of bible prophecy correct
in an unprecedented response to the
grave threat facing all peoples
worldwide from climate change
pope francis and some 40 faith leaders
representing the world's major religions
have joined in an appeal for urgent
action
and the faith leaders represent an
estimated 84
of the world's people
that identify with the faith and they
come from the main christian
denominations
the two main branches of islam sunni and
shia
you judaism hinduism sikhism buddhism
confucianism taoism zoroastrianism and
yainism
christians present at the signing in the
vatican included pope francis patholomia
the first the ecumenical patriarch of
constantinople
metropolitan hillarian of the russian
orthodox church representing
patriarch kirill and archbishop justin
welby of canterbury representing the
anglican communion
they were muslim representatives that
included
grand imam of al-zar
ahmad muhammad al-tayeb from egypt
from the academy of sciences in tehran
while the worldwide jewish community was
represented by rabbi noam marantz of the
international jewish committee for
inter-religious consultations
and rabbi daniel schwartz
of the coalition on the environment and
jewish life
so
many of the churches
seem to have shifted their evangelical
zeal
towards
climate agendas
this is an a glue for ecumenism at this
stage it has nothing to do with the
everlasting gospel
but it is a sideshow that has been
introduced
i find it interesting martin
that there is such thorough preparation
so the first thing was to get all the
faith
leaders on board
then they had a ceremony at the vatican
where
they jointly signed the document
with their intent to present to the cop
26 forum
joe biden will be visiting the pope as
we will see on the 29th of october
just before the opening of the
great event in glasgow
then on the 31st
which is of course
reformation day but it's also halloween
day
where
the
communication between the other world
and
this world was opened up and the the
dead
divide will be removed that is what
halloween is all about
they will be meeting on that day and
then the next day
the great cop 26 will commence so let's
just listen to this news broadcast
on what happened at the vatican with the
faith leaders
religious leaders from around the world
have issued a joint appeal for
international politicians to agree to a
new global deal to combat climate change
christian buddhist muslim and jewish
leaders were among those attending the
gathering at the vatican hosted by the
pope for their part the faith leaders
made a commitment to educating and
influencing their followers about
climate change the bbc's mark lowan is
in rome
they came from across the planet faith
leaders urging politicians to save it
christian and jewish buddhist and muslim
taoist and confucian signing a joint
appeal to world leaders will meet at the
cop 26 in glasgow to commit to net zero
emissions to limit the temperature rise
to 1.5 degrees to support poorer
countries
a pope who is focused on environmental
concern and an archbishop with this
warning
our abuse our war against the climate
affects the poorest among us
reconciliation
with creation
in obedience to our creator
proclaims the love of god
the world
has just
enough time
to get this right
in return the signatories say they'll
educate their faithful spreading the
message of climate awareness
the document was handed to alok sharma
the cop president to take to next
month's summit telling us the faith
leaders are an essential resource the
message from them has been very clear
this is a critical moment for the world
and the message was one of the head and
the heart the scientists telling us the
message from the head is very clear is
that it is humanity that is creating
climate change and we need to act now
and the message of the heart is about
morality
the call is urgent man-made climate
change and fossil fuels have prompted
the warmest decade on record with floods
fires and heat waves this may be the
last chance to halt the damage
religion and science don't always go
hand in hand climate change deniers are
sometimes fueled by religious
conservatives but with research finding
84 percent of people around the globe
identify with a faith world leaders know
that those meeting here today have a
chance of getting their followers to
change their behavior
mark lowen bbc news at the vatican
well martin that is very interesting
so
we have to follow the head which is
reason causing to them
and that's what the scientific world had
to say now
what about all the great disasters of
the past they weren't climate change
correct
especially those that took place before
the industrial revolution
because i hear greta turnberg has taken
the british empire to task for the
industrial revolution yes
while she was partying away
using the benefits of the industrial
revolution yes it's all very interesting
and of course
what brand of science are you following
popular brand or
another brand so this is all very
interesting do
these people that have come together
there representing 84 percent
of the world's population
the question is are they really
representing the truth
or are they representing what is
conveniently perceived as truth at the
present time that that has been put into
the media the whole time
and eventually
you have no other choice
but to believe it correct so if you
repeat something over and over and over
again eventually people might just
believe it right
and that's the way it is the bible tells
us that when they all come together
and they all are of one accord and shout
peace and safety
that's when sudden destruction
comes so this is a very
prophetic picture that we are watching
here at the moment
now
somehow i have the feeling
that many of the decisions
that will be made at cop 26 have had
some preparation of course
definitely and i'm wondering if many of
those decisions haven't already been
made and will just be
basically rubber stamped
at that particular
venue so here's an article from writers
october 14
biden to meet with pope push for global
minimum tax at g20
in rome
so he will meet with pope francis on
october the 29th before attending a
two-day summit of g20 leaders in rome
where he hopes to reach agreement on a
global minimum tax of 15 percent
white house officials said on thursday
at the group of 20 meeting of the
world's major economies biden will focus
on reaching a deal on a global minimum
tax as well as fighting the covet 19
pandemic and boosting the global
economic recovery it's interesting
that this global tax climate change is
still linked to the pandemic yes right
there
they joined it the umbilical cord it's
actually interesting that the alcovet
issue gave this whole climate agenda a
push correct so they used the one to
further the other and i read an article
the other day
that the pandemics are actually on the
increase because of the climate change
so no matter which way you look at it
whether cause or effect they're playing
both sides of the field
if you remember there was that
article that said the earth is
uh mad
it's like a punishment punishment yes
yes okay
at the glasgow climate summit biden's
announcements about u.s commitments of
cash and action to fight global warming
will be closely watched by other
countries and advocacy groups who are
wary of the u.s record on climate change
after trump withdrew from the parrot
climate accord you know what's also
interesting
i watched the video the other day
from the auto manufacturers
which shows that
the electric
vehicles that they are producing at the
moment
really don't contribute to
climb to the climate change agenda at
all
because even one of the very smallest
vehicles you'll have to drive almost 100
000 kilometers before there's any
gain in terms of co2 emission
because the production of the batteries
and everything that is involved and the
and also
the use of the batteries contributes
also
to the co2 emission
and if you have a larger vehicle like a
diesel car or something
you would have to
drive well over 150 000 kilometers
before it will make any difference
whatsoever yeah so in the final analysis
if the vehicles that stayed exactly as
they were
the equation would have remained exactly
the same
a lot of it is purely hype
to achieve a agenda
and we have to see what is the agenda
behind the agenda exactly because the
logic if you really start laying out
logic in some of these areas yes i mean
take africa for instance how you're
going to get that
electrified vehicles in there exactly
there's a lot of logic that's missing so
that's why you have to realize there's
an agenda correct that they're pushing
now the agenda obviously is world
unification that's point number one
they want to have not only the political
leaders but also the industrial leaders
as well as the religious leaders on the
same page
now who separated the nations martin
guarded god separated them right
and the reason for that is so that we
would remain dependent upon him
now
uh it's interesting to me that the
purpose already said or that they have a
point
that we cannot look up
for help in this crisis we have to do
this ourselves
now that in itself
is a departure from faith
i think nimrod had the same sentiment i
think it is the the sentiment of nimrod
exactly
another very interesting feature about
all of this
is the role of the trade unions
now we have statements in the spirit of
prophecy that tell us exactly what we
can expect from the trade unions
but of course if they're going to play a
prominent role then they must be
portrayed as the heroes and not the
villains in all of this right
so it was an interesting
meeting that joe biden had with some of
the leaders of
these unions
let's have a look at that
we were just back in the green room and
the president was talking to president
schuler and jocelyn and he said this is
labor's house
and how often do you hear that
i want to welcome everyone to the white
house and i really mean that
this is your house it's not hyperbole
it's a fact this is your house i
wouldn't be here without you
that's again not hyperbole
in my white house
you'll always be welcome always be
welcome labor will always be welcome
you know you've heard me uh say many
times i intend to be the most pro-union
president
leading the most pro-union
administration in american history
but i think one of the reasons i'm able
to do that is the public is changing too
you've changed the public you've
educated them a lot
and every day we remember
that america wasn't built by wall street
they're not all bad folks on wall street
i'm not suggesting that
but they didn't build america
it was built by the middle class
and unions built the middle class
now
martin that's a very interesting
statement the most
pro-union president in the history of
the united states right
let's read
a statement from the spirit of prophecy
labor unions a source of trouble for
adventists
the trade unions will be one of the
agencies that will bring upon this earth
a time of trouble such as
not been since the world began
a few men will combine to grasp all the
means to be obtained in certain lines of
business trade unions will be formed and
those who refuse to join these unions
will be marked men it's a very
interesting statement
because of these unions and
confederacies it will soon be very
difficult for our institutions to carry
on their work in the cities my warning
is keep out of the cities build no
sanitariums in the cities the time is
fast coming when the controlling power
of the label unions will be very
oppressive
i find it fascinating that there is
legislation
that those who do not conform with
current government decrees
will not be able
to work yes buy or sell
and the labor unions will play a major
role in that so that is a very
oppressive agenda right yeah
it's interesting that she says
that
if you refuse to join these unions you
will be
mocked men
now when i was still with the university
i was the head of our department
that i was in
and as such i was required to join the
labor union
and that was a very interesting event
that happened
and i was called in to the powers that
be
and told that
you know i have to set a good example
and be part of the labor union
and i said i'm terribly sorry
but i won't
i won't join the labor union
so they said to me i have no choice i
have to join the labor union i said no i
won't
i won't join the labor union
and they were they were very upset with
me
and basically it came to the point was
that if you force me i will resign
and
that that created quite a consternation
and they asked me what my problem was i
said it's against my religious and
conviction
so they said
they don't understand because there are
others who of
the same denomination that i belong to
and they're part of the trade union
so what's my
problem the world doesn't understand
this kind of thinking right yeah so i
said to them you know if there are
others
then that's their decision
but as for me
my answer is no
and so they they wanted to know why
so i went to there was a blackboard in
the room that we were talking
so i went to the blackboard and i drew
a circle representing a cake and then i
divided the cake into slices
and
said well this is this industry this is
that industry this is the metal industry
this is the teachers industry etc etc
and each one of them represented by a
trade union
and the more powerful the trade union
the more clout they have
so on an annual basis there would be
negotiations with the trade union and
with the
the powers that be on let's say wage
negotiation
and if you have a powerful trade union
then you can call powerful strikes
and you can
basically paralyze the country
or paralyze the education system or
paralyze whatever you want to paralyze
and the more powerful your trade union
the more powerful your voice
so
if the cake has a certain size
and your trade union is so powerful that
it can increase your slice
then what must that do to the other
slices
decrease it it must decrease the other
that's one aspect
so your voice is able to bring about
a demise of the other party that doesn't
have such a powerful voice
and then if you lay a country lame
that only affects you or does it affect
everyone everyone and then i said
those
basic principles then do they reflect
love your neighbor
no
and if they don't reflect love your
neighbor if they reflect love yourself
more than your neighbor
then
it is not a principle that i would like
to go along with
so i refused to be part of the trade
union
and i told the story last time that when
i was in germany
some of the leaders
within our denomination came to me and
said i wasn't allowed to say anything
negative about trade unions
and i i said why and remember they went
and stood in a huddle and came back and
said
when i asked them okay if i don't say
anything will you accept the blood be on
your head
and
and they agreed that it should be on
their head i mean it's amazing
this is a this is a war
that
stretches across the entire terrain and
as biden said he's the most pro
trade union president
therefore i can assume that he also is
not in harmony with what the bible and
the spirit of prophecy teaches on love
your neighbor no and then also he might
be part of fulfillment of prophecy when
reading these quotes absolutely
absolutely
and then the just for interest sake i
didn't put it in but
there is the whole striketober movement
going on in america where they've got
all these strikes going on
and they're also
some unions that are
calling for
rest now many of these these trade
unions have signed sunday legislation
papers in europe
so that's one of the means to bring
about the time of trouble because if
the world is coerced into that direction
it means that probation will close and
the plagues will fall
so they will be one of the means to
bring about a time of trouble such as
never was
and one of the means that they bringing
this in is they're complaining that
they're working too much hours
so they want reduced hours and therefore
they'll also be calling for a day of
rest and they're already doing it
correct and uh as they did in in greece
for example
they were forced in order to get the
bailout funds a few years ago
they were forced to
change to a six-day work week with fewer
working hours
and you could not
work more hours in order to make up for
any other lost time and therefore sunday
was theoretically the only day that was
available to be arrested
we read in christ objects lessons it is
in a crisis that character is revealed
when the earnest voice proclaimed at
midnight behold the bridegroom cometh go
ye out to meet him
and the sleeping virgins were aroused
from their slumber
it was seen who had made preparation for
the event
both parties were taken unawares
but one was prepared for the emergency
and the other was found without
preparation
so now
a sudden and unlocked for calamity
something that brings the soul face to
face with death
will show whether there is any real
faith in the promises of god
it will show whether the soul is
sustained by grace
the great final test comes at the close
of human probation when it will be too
late
for the soul's need to be supplied
so there is a big surprise coming right
and i think
and the big surprise will
be a calamity
and it can bring you face to face with
death
well didn't covet already
start this ball rolling it started the
ball rolling and if you can't buy and
sell
because of associated legislation
then you could face starvation right and
hardship and we've had numerous of these
leaders tell us that they will be
the next calamities correct
and they're already talking about
marburg and its effects and
all of the issues that the disease will
be similar to ebola etc etc
they're marvelously predictive aren't
they yeah well it's interesting if we
take this part that says
it will show whether there is any real
faith in the promises of god when these
things start happening correct and
we we're receiving so many letters of
people that are so distraught right
but
we now have to have faith in the
promises of god
and she's quite right faith is something
that needs to be exercised
and if we haven't had an opportunity to
exercise our faith thus far
then how will we learn it at the 11th
hour
like it says there it will be too late
for the souls need to be supplied so
many will then go along with the stream
but fall into a greater calamity
i saw our people in great distress
weeping and praying pleading the sure
promises of god
while the wicked were all around us
mocking us threatening to destroy us
they ridiculed our feebleness they
mocked that the smallness of our numbers
taunted us with words calculated to cut
deep they charged us with taking an
independent position
from all the rest of the world they had
cut off our resources
so that we could not buy or sell
and refer to our abject poverty and
stricken condition
they could not see how we could live
without the world we were dependent upon
the world and we must concede to the
customs practices and laws of the world
or go out of it
if we were the only people in the world
whom the lord favored the appearances
were awfully against us
do you have a gut feeling that this is
closer than we think definitely
and
as
as i look out we
want to capitulate
it brings warning signs
if we want to capitulate to to the world
and say this is not the final event
then we could very easily fall into a
trap
but
looking at it prophetically
looking at the churches coming together
signing a climate accord
representing 84 percent of humanity so
they
claim handing that over to the
governments of the world
deciding on a tax a universal tax
and they will be deciding on measures on
how to control it
and it will be the world all together
now one two three here we go
in one accord yeah right and then a
small group says
sorry
will not run in this stream
you will be ridiculed definitely
there will be additional penalties that
will be brought in
you will probably lose your job
and you will be cut off from all human
aid
and then they will start mocking yeah
has it already begun yes
yes
it has already begun yes
and thousands upon thousands
are in the same situation
and many institutions have already
created the legislation that you will no
longer be able to work in this
institution
and that cuts across the board do we
want to be part of that no we have to
get out of there
that is the point we cannot be part of
that
you see the other thing is
where did all these faith leaders go to
sign they went to the vatican
and
pope francis has an encyclical directed
towards climate change and the sunday
legislation are enshrined in there
so you have to put the puzzle together
you have to put it together and if it
fits
then you should beware and you should
take note no we need watchmen on the
walls
of zion
now i was
telling my story yeah and some of the
things that happened to me
and let's be honest some of the things
that are happening even within our
church are
disconcerting to many people including
myself
and as we repeatedly said just because
some people do this that or the other
it doesn't make this church babylon
because this church has a bottom-up
structure yeah by its very nature
we are all brethren
and any major decision that would change
a doctrinal position
has to be taken at a world gathering of
the entire church called a general
conference in session
isn't it the same as the jerusalem
council and all of that that happened in
paul's time exactly no wonder that the
new translations went to change the
wording
so that it looks like a top-down
structure
but it's not a top-down structure
correct it's the the apostles the elders
and the brethren to the brethren and not
the apostles and elders comma to the
brethren that is a distortion of the
text
and many would love that distortion of
the text so the beauty of the advent
movement
is even if
there are people in leadership
that cut across that
directive
doesn't make this church babylon no
whereas if you have a system like the
papacy
where you have ultra montanism one man
makes the decision for all
well if he makes a decision and that is
the decision of the faith
then you're trapped in that in that
system right and unfortunately
all the other denominations work like
that they have a synod right yes so they
make a decision and it affects everyone
no here
the elders
and the brethren have to come together
to make a decision and it must be a
representative of the entire world
church yes it's a unique situation
so martin
when i was banned in germany
because of what happened
at
one of our colleges there in that little
town with that little group
of
bible and testimony believing people had
invited me
that ban was eventually lifted right
but later on that ban was
re-imposed
now there's quite a history to that
because
there was a lot of consternation
when i was banned the first time
and many of the brethren
who then went and studied this issue
including many of the leaders
came to the conclusion that maybe i
shouldn't have been banned in that in
that country
and so they unbanned me
but many were not happy with the fact
that i had been
unbanned
they would prefer
to have that voice silenced entirely
but
it's interesting that some of the
leaders there
had actually entered into an economical
relationship
first as guests
guest members and later as
four members of
the councils
and of course this creates consternation
and some of the leading brethren signed
the document called the chata ecomenica
now if you study that document through
then
you between the lines will find that you
are actually supporting papal supremacy
now anybody in his right mind
can sign something like that is beyond
comprehension
but some of the leaders actually went
into a
formal membership
of
bodies that are affiliated with the
economical council
very often
they don't join the economical council
direct but they join bodies that are
directly affiliated so it's exactly the
same thing
and the question is how can you be a
member of a body
that has the purpose to bring all the
churches back to
a
unified voice
and particularly also of course a
acceptance of the papal position
so
some of the letters that went between
the leadership
in those countries
and that economical representation are
very eye-opening
for example there were
ex letters exchanged between
some of our leaders
and
dr heinz helt who was the bishop
in charge of that economical body
within europe yeah
and the question was then raised how can
you be a member
if you call the pope antichrist
now it's interesting that some of our
leaders then would write and say
that is a 19th century ideology a left
over from the reformation
and some of our other leaders would
write
articles and state that we cannot be
bound to a 19th century ideology
rome certainly has changed
whereas the spirit of prophecy tells us
that rome has not changed yes and we did
a series on the doctrine of the serpent
right
in the what's up prof series
and we had a number of them to show that
there is absolutely no change in rome
so
the only change that we have
is in appearance
that's it
chameleon it's a chameleon she hides her
doctrines under this acceptable
exterior
and
but beneath that acceptable
exterior is the doctrine of the serpent
so it is amazing that these
some of these leaders would then
try to
suggest that they represent the church
they don't represent the church they
represent themselves
and
they are doing it with the full
knowledge of even higher leadership
many of them on that page but many of
them are not
so again let's make it quite clear
that at every single level you will find
people
that are faithfully
adhering to the biblical and
testimony
admonitions
and then you have those that find
it more comfortable to walk the road of
popular acceptance here
now once you have said that
the church
according to them
does no longer adhere to the idea that
the papacy represents the antichrist
then the next step is well if you want
to be a member of this organization
you better keep your subjects in check
so someone like myself
who will say
that the beast of revelation chapter 13
is the papacy
is obviously not very welcome
and therefore any precedent that can be
found
to silence the voice
will be jumped upon correct yes
because that little thorn has to be
taken care of that thorn in the flesh
has to be removed
now just because some in leadership feel
that way doesn't mean that everybody in
leadership feels that way right
so i actually gave a lecture in germany
and one of the issues that came up
was what is the role of literal israel
now why that is important is because
there are so many dispensationalists in
the world that believe that literal
israel has a prominent role to play yes
but the bible is very clear
that those that are in
christ or the israel of god
and so i gave a lecture
where i showed biblically
that the true israel of god is not the
literal israel that exists today
but the spiritual israel
which consists of all peoples every
nation tribe and people
even
from within the jewish ranks right
then i also mentioned that the
present-day jews that are living in
the jewish
state at the moment
are not all literal descendants of judah
so if you want to literalize it
and you want to say that they are the
literal descendants of abraham then in
many a case this is not so
because many of the the jews had been
converted from other nations and become
jews so they weren't the literal
descendants so dispensationalism doesn't
even count
and i mentioned for example the kazaars
and then a huge cry went up
and they said that that was anti-semitic
it's interesting that ten days later
there spiegel
which is like time magazine in germany
produced an article saying exactly the
same thing
but someone found it necessary to accuse
me to the state for anti-semitism
now
there was a major thing and then there
were a couple of of little things like
some faux pas
i just want to ask
it's a very serious accusation in
germany
well if if you are accused of
anti-semitism in germany then the state
is obligated by law
to investigate the issue so to make such
a claim is a very serious accusation
and
there's another thing that happened
i was speaking about the time of the
fascist regime in europe
and how the jews were obligated to wear
a yellow band
now i come from south africa you are
african speaking right martin yes
and you know that in afrikaans
the diminutive is often used
everything is key
which means small right and then you
even have double diminutive yeah
yeah for a little basket a little little
basket so
it's a i found that a very cute aspect
of this language that you use the
diminutive
so if something is small then it is
always key
now
in germany
this can create some confusion
and there was a language barrier
and
you know a lot of my german is
from my childhood
and later in my life i learned afrikaans
and i taught at an afrikaans university
so my afrikaans became almost like a
first language together with english
and your wife is afrikaans and then my
wife was afrikan so then i started
speaking of recurrence at home so this
became
the language
that i was acquainted with and there are
a lot of similarities
between
the germanic languages like dutch and
afrikaans and german
and so for example if you use a
diminutive
in afrikaans
then it is endearing yeah
right it is it's cute and often if you
use the diminutive in german
then it's derogatory
so i i had uh
this nuance problem
and i called it
a tiny band
and
which is a small band
and they found this
terribly offensive
and thought i was being specifically
derogatory
i had another occasion in germany when
that happened to me because in afrikaans
if somebody is exceedingly
sensitive
and uh
kind-hearted and sensitive
then you say she has a small heart yeah
yes a client
yes right you understand somebody that's
sweet that's sweet means they love
easily affectionate yes and and also
easily
slighter
they you have to be careful with them
you have to you know they are sweet and
lovely and beautiful and
and say the kleen harki that's someone
you want to go and give a big hug right
that's it yeah
now if you say in german someone has
a small heart it means they're stinging
ah
and so i said
she had a small heart meaning she was
cute and affectionate and lovely
and they took it and she was mean and
stingy and bitter and they were highly
offended
so sometimes you have these language
barriers
and this also contributed to the issue
and so they used this as a precedent
and they accused me
i explained myself in a letter the
interesting thing is you know people
won't believe you they think you're
lying
but you're my witness you live in this
country right
same one as i
i i got back from germany there and
some had
accused me of this to the state
and there was a huge furore and they
tried to get hold of me by telephone and
they couldn't
but it sounded like the phone was
ringing so obviously i was ignoring them
right now yes
now what had happened was
i lived on a farm
and
that time when i arrived there in one
night they stole
10 kilometers of telephone wires
now not even the government with its
entire team can achieve that in a week
but a thief can achieve that in one
night so there was no communication and
this was of course also taken a miss but
in any case
i was accused of anti-semitism and
immediately banned again
from germany
now the state had to investigate this
issue
and
the police came and they confiscated
my dvds
from the venue where i had given these
lectures and they were live streamed
these lectures
so the state confiscated them and they
said you know you need a lawyer because
this is serious you can you can be put
away in jail
and
i was wondering you know who
who would do something like that who
would go and accuse someone on the basis
of a
biblical
lecture we would do something like that
it would be
of that frame of mind
and
the government investigated this for an
entire year
so they studied the issue
and they also approached the
representatives of the jewish community
the leaders in the in the whole of
germany
and gave them the dvds to watch
so as i said you can do nothing against
the truth you can only do something
for the truth
so then the government officials
investigating the issue they had to
watch all those dvds yeah
and then the jewish representatives they
had to watch all those dvds
and
this sword was hanging over my head you
know will i be called to go
to jail for
anti-semitism
uh and then
finally the government after a year
issued a statement saying
there was no anti-semitism and even the
jewish representatives
said there was zero anti-semitism
and we managed to legally obtain the
charge sheet
and we know who the individual is that
laid the charge
and it's interesting that this
individual is associated
with
some of the or was associated at that
time
with
some of the press organizations within
the church
and that his own facebook page reflects
that he attends jesuit retreats
isn't that interesting martin very
interesting so the government
totally exonerated me on that issue
but do you think they unbanned me
the church yes
no no
do you think they apologized to me no no
they put me through one year
of turmoil
with no apology
now it's interesting again
is it the whole of the leadership that
has this mindset
no
because when they banned me many
realized that this was a trumped up
charge
in fact it was a blatant lie
because
when it comes to
anti-semitism
or racism
i am of the opinion and i've been on
record on many occasions and my whole
life by the way testifies to that issue
that
any one of those isms are abhorrent to
me
and i believe that god created all men
in the image of god
and that doesn't mean that we are all of
the same ideology
but if someone embraces the truth that
makes me happy
and i don't discriminate
what tribe or race or people comes from
they are brothers and sisters in christ
when they accept christ and before that
they can be friends
and they can be mission objects that's
it yeah right
so in any case some of the countries
when i was banned said that this was
this was unfair
and therefore they did not ban me
so i was banned in germany
but i wasn't banned in the neighboring
german-speaking countries
so i could still speak
in german
and
there are open borders today so it
really didn't help them at all
in fact it furthered the debate that's
it
again god allowed this correct
to get it out into a debate correct so
you can do nothing against the truth
and instead of helping their cause
it was actually detrimental to their
cause and i've had so many occasions
like that
where things happened that seemed you
know horrendous
was there a time
when i was
upset about this and about their action
and about their accusations and martin
to this day
there are some of our writers that take
up this mantra and will blatantly state
that i am an anti-semite
which is of course a blatant lie now
what do i do about it well i just ignore
it
is it so i have never said anything
publicly um until this moment about how
i felt but there were times when i was
very bitter
towards the the german leadership
and i was called in to
the division in europe
and the presidency had changed the
president was no longer the one that i
had confronted earlier
who was
the one who
brought in so many of the or permitted
so many of the liberal
movements to enter the church but the
second one he was he was incredibly rude
to me
and accused me of
evangelizing for money he was the one
and so i had many of these discussions
and i explained my situation but did it
change their stance
no
it's interesting in that same building
where you walk through the building the
staff
they embrace you like brothers and
sisters but some of these leaders are
just
unbelievable and they are
of the exact opposite mindset
that i am of for example so obviously we
don't sit around the same table
but many of the other leaders of the
same mindset as i am for example so
within that high echelon of leadership
you have all the groups represented
and
we're not all going to be on the same
page when this thing finally comes to
fruition
some of them wouldn't even talk within
that building because they didn't even
trust their own building or whether it
was wired or not
and would only talk to me outside the
building so it's very strange how some
of these things happen so again i want
to ask the question
do i leave the church
because some of these people sit in
those economical councils
did you stay bitter or did you go with
other bee eventually
well i was a little bit uh no
let me not lie
i was
quite upset with what they had done and
people had found me and there were
lawyers that were offering their
services for free to help me and i said
no i don't need a lawyer
i have an advocate
i have the best advocate in the universe
because i know what i said and i know
that it's been misrepresented and i know
that it is being distorted by people
that have an agenda
and therefore
i left it to god and after one
year i was totally exonerated right and
then you became
better and no longer before that okay
long before that year was over
in fact i was
sitting in my room one day and i was
mulling over these things and all these
events and all the
the distortions and the blatant lies
that were told
and i thought to myself
how do you feel about these people
and i realized that my feelings weren't
very kind
as i'm sure a lot of people feel well
i will admit my feelings weren't very
kind towards them and
and i thought to myself you know what
are you going to walk around
the rest of your life with this
animosity in your in your heart
and so i took a
a walk in the mountain
all by myself and i went and sat on a
rock on the mountain and i
i spoke to god for a
long long time
and i said to him you know
i don't really want these feelings
can you do something about them please
can you please take them away
so i prayed and i asked the lord to take
away these feelings and
i felt better and i went home
and something very strange happened
this feeling of animosity
changed
to a feeling of pity
and then i could handle it yeah
i actually petite them i felt sorry for
them
because
what road were they on
they were acting contrary to the spirit
of of the bible they were acting
contrary to the spirit of prophecy and
they had entrapped themselves
in systems
that would not allow them to live the
truth as we have received it as a
denomination
let me just give you one example martin
here's an article it's from 2009 already
it's in german and you can see it has
the sign over here of the artse car and
it clearly says the ecomena which means
the economical council
of which
many of the leaders
in europe are a member in germany
now
it says here that
the chairman of this committee
warns against fundamentalism
and he says fundamentalism this is now
in german
and
creationism
and then the the redaction adds here
this is the teaching
that god
created the world in
six
days
that this teaching has no place
in the economical council
this is the opinion of
the one leading out so i want to ask you
martin
can two walk together unless they agree
not at all no so what are they doing in
that council right something you had to
give if you go correct to that council
so as long as they sit in that council
they will not unban me no
now do you think that the general person
that is a member of this church and they
see this hypocrisy
do you think that they
will not come to a point of having to
make a decision yeah that's why god
brought it to the fall exactly you can
do nothing against the truth only for
the truth
now as i already stated if i'm banned in
one country
the the other country which also has
echelons of leadership in the church
they don't ban me in fact they invite me
yeah
does that create tension between the two
groups definitely
absolutely i was in in one country
and they told me about the pressure that
is brought to bear
upon them to conform to a liberal agenda
for example they have youth festivals
where they have music festivals which
are more fit for a rock stage
than for a church that represents
the bible and the spirit of prophecy
in fact in one of those
concerts
organized by the highest echelon of
leadership
they were doing michael jackson
representations
complete
with all the gyrations that go along
with them
and one of the presidents of the other
country a leader
had a long conversation with me
and said he's under pressure to comply
and to send the youth there
but he refused
he said i cannot subject my the youth of
our church to this kind of atmosphere
to which then often threats will come of
the financial nature
but you know martin if we stand for
truth
god will honor that decision and the the
gates of heaven will be opened wide and
the windows in heaven and he will pour
out a blessing
if you stand for truth
truth is made prominent amen
it's not only that youth gatherings are
organized where
questionable things take place
but even in the other echelons
some of the things are absolutely
amazing and you would think that you are
part of the world rather than
part of the ministry of christ see if we
can just read two statements here
this comes from christian education
there's a great need of elevating the
standard of righteousness in our schools
to give instructions after god's order
should christ enter our institutions for
the education of the youth
he would cleanse them as he cleansed the
temple
banishing many things that have a
defiling influence
many of the books which the youth study
would be expelled and their places would
be filled with others that would
inculcate substantial knowledge
and abound in sentiments which might be
treasured in the heart
in precepts that might govern the
conduct
shall the sentiments of unbelievers the
expressions of dissolute men be
advocated as worthy of the students
attention
because they are the productions of men
whom the world admires as great thinkers
shall a michael jackson concert be held
within the ranks of god's people
shall men professing to believe in god
gather from these unsanctified authors
their expressions and sentiments and
treasure them up as precious jewels
to be stored away amongst the riches of
the mind
god forbid
here's one from councils to parents and
teachers but there has been a class of
social gatherings in so and so
of an entirely different character
parties of pleasure
that have been a disgrace to our
institutions and to the church
they encourage pride of dress pride of
appearance self-gratification hilarity
and trifling
satan is entertained as an honored guest
and takes possession of those who
patronize these gatherings
a view of one such company was presented
to me where were assembled those who
profess to believe the truth
one was seated at the instrument of
music and such songs were poured forth
as made the watching angels weep
there was mirth there was coarse
laughter there was abundance of
enthusiasm and a kind of inspiration
but the joy was such as satan only is
able to create
this is an enthusiasm and infatuation of
which all who love god
will be
ashamed
now
button if you stand for this
sentiment
then you will come into serious conflict
with many within the church yes
do i leave the church because there is
conflict on this issue no
and the thing that has to
uplift you is this this has been 470
years already
so there are many many things which can
be twisted
why are these people so concerned
about economical relationships
because they want to
seem to be part
of
whatever is happening in those
echelons right yeah
and so many of the doctrines too
will be
manipulated
the antichrist will no longer be who he
was
we have to
put that into a bottle called 19th
century thinking we're in
a new mode at the moment the
relationship with other churches
you know martin is very difficult to
change an entire church to accept
something new
so it's better rather to make a
compromise and say that we are a mosaic
of truth
so all of these streams of thinking
run within
the church
but they are not the official teaching
of the church
the bible
and the testimony that is the official
teaching
now it's always interesting to me
that there where power is yielded
very often that is the target
where the enemy will introduce those
very things right that's it
you were mentioning earlier about
we shouldn't be scared
to be cut off
from
maybe financial means or anything
because we can god will always
provide a way
again let's use the title
you can do nothing
against the truth
but for the truth if god wants to make a
truth prominent
he will open the doors
he will make a way
you might be banned in one place
but
the next place will not ban you
you might be uninvited at one place and
be invited
right next door
and this creates much consternation
but if god opens a door
then you must walk through it because
sometimes like you mentioned before you
get threats that you will be also even
financially cut off
if you don't adhere correct
but if you stand for principle god opens
away
now i've had so many occasions where
this has happened i've been invited many
many times and then the invitation has
been withdrawn often
because some leaders will interfere
strange enough
if you have been
uninvited
then other leaders might come up for you
and you have to be reinvited in another
form
creates much consternation
and in many of my lectures or in many of
my series i've been officially invited
that one president accused me of
inviting myself
and i made him understand in no
uncertain terms that i've never ever in
my entire life invited myself
in fact i have a problem
deciding
where to say no and where to say yes and
it often takes a lot of prayer
and some of them
they will as i said before warn against
attending my meetings
in one of my australian meetings one of
the presidents said that anybody who
attends my meetings
will be disfellowshipped in the first
place what gives anyone the right to
make a statement like that no it might
not have been an official capacity but
in a in a fit of anger
but this is in any case what the members
told me
and
as a consequence a few thousand people
turned up to my lectures you can do
nothing against it you could only do
something forward the best advertisement
that you can have
is when this happens
so i was invited to speak in a north
american
camp meeting
and
there's always a discussion
let's get that speaker
and then there will be those that object
to that speaker and eventually the
majority won the day and i was invited
then higher echelons get involved and
say no you will uninvite him
because he said this that that and the
other all right
and
it's always the same issues
but this is what happens to me all the
time or happened to me when we could
still travel
just one interesting story how how god
works
so i was invited to a very large
conference in the north american
continent
to come and be a camp meeting speaker
and then
almost at the last moment
they had this
pressure from above and they phoned me
and said
you at one stage said this that and the
other and i said yes i
did report that because that's what the
news said i
reported what the news said
and they said well
it would be better if i didn't come
and then another conference
within the same area invited me
and so there were two
and so
they were both the leadership positions
but i was the speaker and the one and
not in the other and the interesting
thing is many from the other one also
came to this one so it didn't it didn't
affect anything it still went ahead
although
the ones that had invited me said no but
others took their place on another
occasion and i always find these things
i leave it totally to god yeah
i will not force my way into anything
but i was invited
by certain people in a very important
section of the north american continent
and
pressure was brought to bear to cancel
but some felt no
this pressure is not warranted and we
will continue so we will arrange our own
they had some support but many in the
leadership said no
we will
not assist you in any way if you go
ahead with this thing
and some of these people you know they
didn't have great resources how they're
going to arrange a
camp meeting with hundreds of people
attending you know that's a that's quite
a procedure how are you going to do this
and they didn't have many resources
and so they didn't have a place because
they were prohibited from using any of
the venues
and so there was a lot of pressure on
them and so they came together as a
group and they prayed and said lord how
are we going to do this
and
then someone said you know i have a tent
now when we speak about a tent we're
speaking about a huge tent
i could make that available to you guys
for free here it is
but it had no polls or anything to to
put it up and where you gonna hold this
venue
so somebody else suggested something
else and they found a
another denomination's camping ground
but it didn't have any lecturing
facilities it was just a camping ground
with
you know washroom facilities but nothing
else
and so
they procured that but now they had this
huge tent
and they had no poles
and then another brother said you know
what i have a piece of land
that has a lot of trees on it that have
to be thinned out anyway
let's go and have a look whether any of
those might work so they went to this
piece of land and there were lots of
these trees that were tall and slender
and young
so they cut all the poles that they
needed for free
and
made the stent to stand
where it was to stand but then they had
another problem
they didn't have any chairs
now where were they going to get chairs
so they tried to hire chairs now
it's quite a while back so i can't
remember you know the exact figures but
i think it was something like if you
hire the chairs if you rented them it
was three dollars a chair
now if you have
500 chairs
that's 1
per day that's a lot of money for people
that are already you know struggling
so they couldn't rent chairs so they
were in a quandary
and then they get a phone call from
somewhere else
that had heard about this quandary and
said you know what you guys can come and
get archers you can buy them
you can buy them for one dollar a chair
and so off they went with a whole lot of
trucks thinking how they're going to
load all these chairs
and they arrived there and all these
chairs were fold up chairs
on trolleys
so he just wheeled the trolley onto
the the trucks and off they went they
got all the chairs so they got the venue
they got the the facility they got the
poles they got the chairs
and they put all the stuff together now
this was all before i got there of
course right they just told me the story
and then when i arrived there
it was the most
fantastic
camp meeting that you can imagine
it was so
how shall i say it so simple
so
godly
they had activities
so now between between lectures they had
activities and the way in which they
dealt
with these things they had courses on
survival
they had courses on furniture making
you know interesting things of a
practical nature they took the bible and
the spirit of prophecy and they read and
they tried to figure out what would be
the right way to go ahead
with this kind of thing
and
when you walked into that place with
these people
that had gone out on a limb
and that had walked in faith
and god had supplied everything that
they
needed didn't come out of their riches
it came
in spite of their poverty right
the the the brotherly interaction that
you had
was of a level that i have seldom
experienced
you felt
one everybody was of one accord it was
almost like being in heaven
and
you know if if
everything is there and the money is
there and the venues are great and all
of these things
that often leads to a show
but here
the spirit of god was working
and it was one of the most
blessed experiences that you could have
so in spite of
all the opposition
god always makes something good come out
of it
and i don't know what happened
thereafter but i have a feeling that
from that very place
there will come a revival in the north
american continent
because if it started
there it might also
end there
so martin you can do nothing against the
truth and sometimes you're not in a hard
place and sometimes you feel
as though you are sorely treated
but god always turns it around and makes
something good come out of it
so don't despair when things get tough
don't look at people or what this leader
does or that leader does there are other
leaders
that will do exactly the opposite
and whatever creates
a debate
around issues of truth
you can be sure that god is working and
leading minds to study the issue for
themselves
how many people have said how dare you
say that
and a few months later say but i read it
now
now i understand
so don't despair
and even if we make mistakes ourselves
you know we are human we are fallible
we're not popes
we occasionally
get things wrong
maybe many times get things wrong
but
if the desire is there
to have it based on on truth on the
bible in the spirit of prophecy
then
my experience is
if it stands there
you can trust it that's it
like you said in that in the previous
one or somewhere said
i think it was a song you mentioned yes
the bible says it
i believe it i believe it that's the way
it is that's it let's close with prayer
heavenly father
this is your church
this is the crucible
in which character is developed
if everything was plain sailing how
would we develop a character it's like a
marriage
you have to
wrestle through your character defects
and you have to allow god
to change us so that we can better
reflect his glory
help us to be
builders
and not destroyers in jesus name amen
amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe
click here
when the bell appears
click again to get notifications
to watch the next video
click here
thank you